yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
in Captain America Civil War we learn
that with great power comes a great deal
of government supervision team I man's
okay with that team cap not so much and
so the scene is set for the third of
this year's ideological bus stops
between comic book characters first we
had der devil versus a Punisher in
season 2 of Marvel's Netflix show and
then of course we had Batman V Superman
but now it's time for two of the
linchpins of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe to faceoff in Captain America
Civil War and it's been well worth the
wait
Captain America Civil War certainly has
a lot of plates to keep spinning between
being the third installment in a Captain
America trilogy a sort of sequel to age
of ultron an introduction to several new
superheroes and an Avengers movie in
everything of the name but don't worry
as directors Anthony and Joe Russo and
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely
deftly keep those plates in pretty
magnificent motion throughout the
chemistry between the movies many actors
and the connection you feel to their
characters has been slowly and steadily
cooking for a number of years now and
civil war makes the very most of that at
the heart of the movie a powerful pitch
perfect performances from Chris Evans
and Robert Downey jr. each actor is so
obviously at ease and their roles and
has developed their respective
characters of Steve Rogers and Tony
Stark's so well over the course of
numerous films there's a real pleasure
to watch them on screen as they battle
not only each other but their own in a
conflicts and it's fantastic seeing the
welcome return of so many other familiar
faces to Scarlett Johansson's Black
Widow Anthony Mackey's Falcon Don
Cheadle's war machine and Jeremy
Renner's Hawkeye all get their moments
in and out of battle they're inevitably
some get more time to enjoy the
spotlight than others Sebastian Stan is
great as Bucky Barnes aka the Winter
Soldier and his rapport with on-screen
best friends Chris Evans feels
wonderfully real as the mysterious Zemo
Daniel Bruhl gives a nicely grounded
understated performance and paul bettany
continues the fine workers vision he
starts in an age of Ultron and he and
Elizabeth Olsen gets and delightful
scenes together which both actors
cleverly under play as they build their
characters and intriguing ways Paul
Rudd's arrival as ant-man is a real joy
and he contributes some great moments to
the movie I also really like Emily
VanCamp
Sharon Carter aka agent 13 and though
her role is a smaller supporting one
compared to the movies many superheroes
she does get more to do in this movie
however one particular moment between
castor and another character feels
lacking incredible build-up and as ever
Akane Ross Martin Freeman feels a little
wasted right from the very start the
action is full-on with plenty of
wonderfully choreographed and shot
scenes that show the influence of movies
including the raid and Bourne franchises
and demand your attention at every twist
and turn of the camera and there's one
particular action sequences personally
spectacular and is right up there with
the very best superhero action scenes
ever the movie contains a wealth of
humor - which comes from a variety of
sources including Tony Stark though he's
necessarily a little more subdued than
usual
Vulcan Vision ant-man and the new
superhero kid on the block Spider Man
also add a hell of a lot in the comedy
departments speaking of spider-man and
Peter Parker his scenes were an absolute
treat as the latest actor to support the
Spidey spandex Tom Holland is simply
outstanding really embodying the
youthful spirit of the character
spider-man has always been one of my
favorite comic book characters and I
cannot wait to see Holland continue the
great groundwork he played for the
character here in his own film as for
black panther are other new super
arrival actor chadwick boseman makes a
great first impression in the role
playing some really interesting
character driven moments as well as
standing out in plenty of acrobatic
action filled scenes based on this movie
I'm certainly looking forward to his
first solo outing in 2018 Owen Stanley
gets the most fabulous cameo which is
now one of my favorites one thing the
movie doesn't always get quite right
though is the level of consequences for
some of its plot points but I can't say
any more about that without spoiling it
for you and I don't want to do that by
the way if you like Easter eggs and
Civil Wars got stacks to keep a look out
for I've got a video about that on the
way and I'll make the link live here as
soon as it's ready so to sum up Captain
America Civil War is a compelling piece
of cinema and one of the MC used best
movies so far which for me means it's up
there with the first Iron Man movie the
first Avengers outing the Winter Soldier
and guardians of the galaxy
it's action scenes are a breathless
pleasure it's humor is OnPoint it's cast
is a delight to watch and it's got a
wealth of Easter
which is enough to send you to nerdvana
it's a movie that deserves your Peter
viewings and I'm already looking forward
to watching it again Captain America
Civil War gets four and a half out of 5
flicks now I'd love to know what you're
looking forward to about Captain America
Civil War and if you've already seen it
what did you think let me know in the
comments below I've got lots more
Captain America Civil War videos on the
way including an Easter Egg video and
more spoilery discussion of the movie
they'll all be here in my Civil War
playlist along with tons of cast
interviews if you enjoyed this video I
really appreciate your liking and
sharing it and subscribing thanks for
watching and see you next time you'll be
going movie lovers